دي صور من زلزال ازميت اللي معظمكم سمع
عنه وضرب هرب تركيا من 24 سنه تقريبا سنه
1999 زلزال كانت قوته سبعه فاصل اربعه على
مقياس ريختر ولحد اول فبراير اللي فات كان
تاني اكبر كارثه طبيعيه في تاريخ تركيا
الحديث بعد زلزال ارسنجان سنه 1939 اللي
تسبب في وفاه اكتر من 30 الف شخص واصابه
100 الف تقريبا لكن اللي مش معروف بشكل
كبير هي الخسائر الضخمه اللي تسبب فيها
زلزال ازميت ضرب سبعه مدن ولايات رئيسيه
في منطقه مرمره وراح ضحيته اكتر من 18000
شخص وتسبب في اصابه حوالي 49 الف غيرهم
وتدمير 93 الف وحده سكنيه و15 الف وحده
تجاريه او مصنع وقدر بشكل جزئي ب 240 الف
وحده تانيه بين السكني والاعمال ولان
منطقه مرمره كانت ولا تزال من المناطق
المهمه جدا للاقتصاد التركي وللص تحديدا
فالسلساله تسبب في محو ما بين 9.13 مليار
دولار امريكي من الناتج المحلي مباشره
وحوالي واحد ونصف لتلاته ونص مليار دولار
كمان دفعهم قطاع التامين اما بالنسبه
لاثاره على ميزانيه الحكومه التركيه من
حيث خسائر عائدات الضريبيه والمعونات
وتعويضات البطاله وتكلفه اعاده الاعمار
فده كله وصلت فاتورته لسته فاصل اتنين
مليار دولار والارقام دي بحسابات النهارده
تقريبا الضعف بعد حساب معدل التضخم من
وقتها طبعا دي ما كانتش كل الخساير احنا
ممكن نتتبع حجم الخساره وقتها في كل
القطاعات المتاثره وهنجمع مليارات
الدولارات من الخسائر غير المباشره لكن مش
هنقدر نعمل ده علشان الوقت لكن المقاربه
دي مهمه علشان تعرفوا الكوارث الطبيعيه
الكبرى بتاثر ازاي على اقتصادات اي بلد
مهما كان قوي علشان كده حاليا وبعد
السلسال اللي ضرب جنوب التركي والشمال
السوري في 6 فبراير اللي فات
في وفاه 52 الف شخص واصابه اكتر من 120
الف تانيين علشان يبقى اكبر كارثه طبيعيه
واجهه تركيا في اخر 100 سنه على الاقل
هنلاقي ان تركيا تحديدا بما انها المتضرر
الاكبر بتواجه ازمه وتحديات اضخم بكتير
ازمه كانت باينه بوضوح في كلمه الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان من ايام قليله
لمؤتمر المانحين في بروكسل بلجيكيه واللي
اتعمل يوم 20 مارس اللي فات ده وقدر فيه
اردوغان تكلفه اعاده الاعمار اللي
هتتحملها بلاده بمبلغ رهيب هو 104 مليار
دولار فبجانب الخسائر البشريه اللي لا
يمكن تعويضها باي شكل وعشرات الالاف من
الضحايا والنصابين ربنا يرحمهم او يشفيهم
المقارنه دي تخلينا نسال شويه اسئله مهمه
جدا يا ترى الاقتصاد التركي خسر ايه بسبب
سلسال كهرمان مارعشتها والخسائر دي مؤقته
ولا دايمه وايه اوجه الشبه والاختلاف بين
الزلزال الاخير وبنزل 19
90 اللي حكينا عنه هل التاثير الاقتصادي
للسلسله الاخيره هيكون اخف ولا اشد وهل
تركيا هتقدر تتعافى من اثاره وازاي
التعافي ده هيحصل وفي وقت قد ايه وايه
التحديات او المعوقات اللي هتواجه خطط
التعافي واعاده الاعمار بعينه من الاسئله
المهمه جدا اللي هنجاوب عليها مع بعض في
حلقه النهارده بس قبل ما نبدا بفكركم
بالاشتراك في القناه وبفكركم برضو ان كل
حلقاتنا اللي فاتت مترجمه للغه الانجليزيه
فما تنسوش تشاركوها مع اصحابكم الاجانب
وتعرفوهم علينا انا اشرف ابراهيم ما
المقبل الاقتصادي
عايز اشكر شركه اكس نسل العالميه لرعايتها
الحلقه واكثر هي شركه عندها خبره طويله في
الاسواق الماليه بحجم تداولات شهريه تجاوز
الاتنين تريليون دولار ليه بنصح بالتعامل
معك علشان اربع مميزات الاولى انها مرخصه
ومراقبه من هيئه رقابيه التانيه بعرف اسحب
فلوسي فيها بشكل فوري بدون تدخل بشري
الثالثه ان عملتهم مخفضه الرابعه بقى ان
التداول بيتنفذ بسرعه تقدر تفتح حساب
اسلامي لا محدود وتبدا تشتري وتبيع الاسهم
والدهب هتلاقوا لينك ليهم تحت الفيديو في
تعليقات فيسبوك الحقيقه ان مهمه حصر اضرار
السلسله الاخير مهمه مش سهله ابدا لاننا
رغم مرور شهرين تقريبا على الكارثه فاحنا
لازلنا في مرحله حصر الاضرار اللي بتشمل
المباني والبنيه التحتيه المنهاره
والتاثير السلبي على القطاعات الاقتصاديه
المختلفه واسواق العمل وغيرها وعلشان كده
هنلاحظ وجود اختلافات كبيره جدا بين
الجهات اللي حاولت تقدر خسائر الزلزال
شركه المتخصصه في تح المخاطر قدرت الخسائر
الاقتصاديه المباشره للزلزال بعشرين مليار
دولار في حين ان شركه الخدمات المصرفيه
والماليه العالميه جيب مورجان قدرتها ب 25
مليار دولار اما اكبر رقم فصدر عن اتحاد
الشركات والاعمال التركي اللي قدر الخساير
بحوالي 84 مليار دولار وده رقم ضخم جدا
مرعب وبيعادل 10% تقريبا من الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي التركي اما تقديرات البنك الدولي
فجت في منطقه وسط بين الارقام دي في دراسه
عن مؤسستين تابعتين للبنك في 27 فبراير
اللي فات اظهرت ان الاضرار المباشره
للزلزال تقدر ب 34.2 مليار دولار ما يعادل
تقريبا 3.8% من الناتج المحلي الاجمالي
لتركيا للسنه اللي فاتت 2022 ايوه يعني
الاضرار اللي بمليارات الدولارات دي حصلت
ازاي برضو بصوا يا جماعه علشان تفهموا حجم
اللي حصل في 116 الف مبنى سكني وخدمى
ومنشات زراعيه تهدموا او تضرروا
والمصانع والالات المتضرره وانخفاض
الانتاج المحلي لنفسه بسبب اغلاق المصانع
ده غير نقص العائدات الضريبيه وتعويضات
البطاله وحاجات تانيه كتير العوامل
المتداخله دي بتخلي الاقتصاديين دايما
مهتمين بالاثار الاقتصاديه بعيده المدى
للكوارث الطبيعيه اكتر من اهتمامهم
بالخسائر الاقتصاديه المباشره لكن بما ان
مفيش حد مننا عنده بلوره سحريه يقدر يشوف
بها المستقبل فالطريقه الوحيده لتوقع اداء
اقتصاد اي دوله بعد تعرضها لكارثه طبيعيه
ضخمه هتكون مقارنتها بحالات شبيهه يا اما
لدول تانيه عندها نفس ظروف تركيا
الاقتصاديه وواجهه مشاكل مشابهه يا اما
بتجربه في الماضي لنفس الدوله وفي حاله
تركيا احنا نقدر نعمل الحاجتين مين اللي
حاول يقيس الاثار البعيده دي اللي حاول
يعمل كده هو مركز ابحاث السياسات
الاقتصاديه الاوروبي سيبر في دراسه طلعها
يوم 26 فبراير اللي فات يعني بعد 3 اسابيع
تقريبا من الكارثه وباتباع المنهجيه محدده
اللي لسه قايل لكم عليها لا ان الدول
المتاثره بكارثه طبيعيه كبرى ناتجها المحل
الاجمالي بينخفض بنسبه واحد في الميه في
السنه اللي بعد الكارثه وضمن الدول دي
كانت تركيا نفسها بعد سلسال ازميت في
التسعينات طيب هل ده معناه ان الناتج
المحلي لتركيا هينخفض بنسبه واحد في الميه
خلال السنه الجايه برضو ولا الوضع هيكون
مختلف بدايه خلوني اقول لكم ان خساره واحد
في الميه للناتج المحلي الاجمالي عموما مش
حاجه قليله خاصه اننا بنتكلم عن تركيا
اللي ناتجها الاجمالي سنه 2022 وصل ل 905
مليار دولار يعني الواحد في الميه ده
يساوي خساره تركيا لتسعه مليار دولار
مباشره لكن الكلام ده مش معناه ان الزلزال
الحالي هيكون زي سلسله التسعينات لاننا لو
اتكلمنا عن الخساير والاضرار الماديه
المباشره فواضح ان السلسال المره دي كان
اقوى والدمار اللي اتسبب فيه اكبر بكثير
لكن لو حبينا نبص على الاثار بعيده المدى
الاقتصاد التركي هنلاقي الامور مختلفه
شويه السبب الرئيسه للاختلاف ده هو الفرق
في الاهميه الاقتصاديه بين المنطقتين اللي
ضربهم الزلزاليه يعني الزلزال سنه 1999
ضرب قلب المناطق الصناعيه لتركيا ورغم ان
الولايات الاربعه الرئيسيه المتضرره وهي
كوجالي وسكريا وجولو فيها حوالي 4% بس من
سكان البلد ويمكن ده السبب ان الخسائر
البشريه كانت اقل ساعتها بشكل ملحوظ لكن
الولايات دي كانت مسؤوله بشكل مباشر عن
حوالي 7% من الناتج المحلي الاجمالي
التركي
و14% من القيمه الصناعيه المضافه الاهم من
كده ان المناطق دي لها روابط مع مراكز
اقتصاديه كبيره زي اسطنبول اكبر مدينه في
تركيا وبورصه رابع اكبر مدينه والمركز
الصناعي المهم والنتيجه لده كان في ضرر
واسع جدا اصاب قطاعات الطاقه والنقل
والبنيه التحتيه للاتصالات وغيرها وبشكل
عام المناطق اللي تعرضت
مرتفعه لكنها بتساهم بحوالي 9% بس من
الناتج المحلي الاجمالي مش معنى كلامنا ان
المناطق دي مش مهمه او مش مؤثره لكنها مش
زي المراكز الصناعيه والتجاريه الخمسه
الكبرى اللي هي اسطنبول وانقره
وبورصه واللي بتشكل مع بعض
53.7% من الناتج المحلي الاجمالي التركي
واللي كانت بعيده عن اثار الزلزال وده
بينطبق برضو على المراكز السياحيه
الرئيسيه اللي هي اسطنبول وانطاليا وعدمنا
اللي بيستضيفوا حوالي 77% من اجمالي عدد
السياح في تركيا ثانويه في فرق مهم غير
كده كمان وهو ان التامين ضد السلاسل منتشر
دلوقتي بشكل اكبر بكتير مقارنه بسنه 1999
والسبب الرئيسي في ده هو ان السلطات
التركيه قامت ساعتها بفرض نظام تامين
اجباري اسمه مجمع التامين التركي ضد
الكوارث او تي سي اي بي وده تحت اشراف
سلطه الكوارث الطبيعيه التركيه ده باختصار
التامين اجباريه لاصحاب المنازل للتحوط ضد
الزلازل والكوارث الطبيعيه بيفرد على
اصحاب المنازل دفع اقساط تامين اجباريه
لما منازلهم بهدف تغطيه الاضرار اللي
هتصيبها في حالات الزلازل او الكوارث
المظله دي حاليا بتغطي حوالي 56% من
الوحدات السكنيه التركيه كمتوسط عام طبعا
المظله التامينيه التركيه لسه اضعف من
نظراتها في دول اوروبا مثلا لكنها
بالتاكيد افضل بكتير عن التسعينات ومع ان
تركيا بتواجه ازمه اقتصاديه كبيره اتسببت
في انهيار قيمه الليره وزياده تضخم لكن
رغم كده فالاقتصاد التركي لسه عنده نقطه
قوه واضحه وهي حجم الدين للناتج المحلي
الاجمالي ولا نسبته حاليا
37% ودي نسبه مش مرتفعه ابدا وبتمنح
الحكومه حيز مالي لتمويل جزء من تدابير
الاعمار من خلال الديور لكن ثمن ده ممكن
يبقى رفع اسعار الفايده علشان جذب
المقرضيه وموضوع الفايده ده رئيس التركي
اردوغان عنده مشكله معه زي ما كتير من
حضراتكم عارفين اكيد زي ما شرحنا بالتفصيل
في حلقه انهيار الليره التركيه اللي لازم
تشوفوها من هنا اللي فات ده ياخدنا السؤال
مهم جدا هل الدول ممكن تتعافى بشكل دائم
من اثار الكوارث الطبيعيه ويرجع اقتصادها
زي الاول او احسن كمان ولا زي ما بيقولوا
اللي اتكسر ما بيتصلحش السؤال ده هتجاوبني
عليه باختصار
متخصصه في اقتصاديات الكوارث بكليه الشؤون
العامه والعالميه جامعه اي اي الاسبانيه
بتقول لنا انه في اكتر من سيناريو ممكن
يحصلوا هنا بعضها سيناريوهات سيئه
ومتشائمه جدا وبعضها سيناريوهات متفائله
في السيناريو الاول هيقل الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي للدوله المصابه بالكارثه وهينخفض
النمو في البدايه بسبب الدمار اللي اعصاب
المنشات والبنيه التحتيه واللي خلى انتاج
السلع والخدمات داخل الدوله تكون اقل لكن
خلال فتره صغيره هيبدا نمو الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي تاني مع استئناف جهود اعاده
الاعمار لكن الناتج نفسه مش هيوصل ابدا
لنفس المستوى اللي ماشي عليه قبل الكارثه
السيناريو تاني الكراسي فعلا هو ان النمو
نفسه ما يتعافاش ابدا وده معناه ان انا مش
بس بنتكلم عن خساره معقده مهما كانت كبيره
لكننا بنتكلم على تباطئ كامل ومزمن تقريبا
في مسار الاقتصاد يعني اللي كنا بنحققه في
سنه بقى محتاج سنتين واللي محتاج خمس سنين
بقى محتاج عشر سنين وهكذا السيناريو
الثالث بقى هو النموذج المثالي اللي
بتتمناه اي دوله مصابه بكارثه طبيعيه وهو
ان النمو هيتعافى بمعدلات اسرع من الطبيعي
في السنوات الاولى بعد الكارثه بسبب
الانفاق الكبير على خطط التعافي وده معناه
ان الكارثه مش هيكون لها اي تاثير طويل
الامد واثرها هتقتصر على حجم الدمار
والتاثر المؤقت لكن الانتاجيه خلال الفتره
اللي بعدها على طول بس عندنا سيناريوهين
كمان متفائلين جدا واحد منهم بيقولنا ان
طفره والانشاءات بعد الكارثه هتكون ضخمه
وده هيخلي النمو يسيب بمعدلات كبيره جدا
وبعد كده هيبدا يتباطئ تاني للمعدلات
الطبيعيه قبل الكارثه والتاني بيفترض
باختصار ان الزلزال او الكارثه الطبيعيه
دي جت علشان تدمر المؤسسات الاقل انتاجيه
في الدوله وان المصانع والمؤسسات الجديده
اللي هتتبني هتكون اكثر كفاءه يعني معدلات
نموه اكبر وارقام ناتج اجمالي اكبر بكتير
من قبل الكارثه والسيناريو ده خبراء
الاقتصاد بيسموه بسيناريو التدمير
الابداعي او كريات في معظم الحالات خبراء
الاقتصاد انهم دكتور ستيفاني نفسها
بيرجحوا حصول السيناريو الثاني وهو ان
معدل النمو هيتعافى لكن الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي هيفضل اقل من الوضع قبل الزلزال
وده زي ما قلنا مش سيناريو سيء قوي خاصه
لما تكون الكارثه الطبيعيه بحجم سلسال
تركيا والشمال السوري الرئيس التركي
اردوغان وعد بان اعاده الاعمار حتم في
غضون سنه واحده بس ورغم ان تركيا لها
سابقه كويسه في عمليه اعاده اعمار ما بعد
زلزال ازميت واللي تمت بمساعده البنك
الدولي في سنتين ونصف بس ووصفت بانها اسرع
عمليه اعاده اعمار في العالم واتبنى فيها
الاف المباني رغم ده الوقت اللي حطه
اردوغان لاكمال اعاده الاعمار يبدو انه
متفائل شويه رغم اختلاف الظروف والزمن لكن
احتمال كبير ان سنه واحده ما تكونش كافيه
لترميم اللي دمروا الزلزال الضخم في
الجنوب وده اللي عشار ليه اجاره شيبر اللي
كان ماسك مدير البنك الدولي في تركيا
اثناء فتره زلزال ازمات قال اول الشهر
اللي فات اني قعدت الاعمار بالسرعه دي
هتتطلب اختصار مراحل كثيره مهمه وهو هنا
بيشير ان السرعه دي قد يكون لها اضرار على
المدى البعيد وشاركته الراي ده ديفيا
بروفيسيرا المساعده في تخطيط المدن جامعه
تويوتا الامريكيه واللي قالت ان التعافي
المدروس هو المطلوب وان ده يتضمن كبح جماح
الرغبه العالمه الحك والشعبيه في ظل اي
ازمه للتعافي السريع لكن المؤكد ان عمليه
اعاده الاعمار هتكون في ظروف اقل في
وطاقتها الاقتصاديه من ظروف الزلزال سنه
1999 بكل الاشكال لحد هنا انا خلصت كلامي
وباكد ان كل كلامنا ده مش هينسينا ان
الخسائر البشريه لن تعوض ربنا يرحم
الضحايا وصبر اهاليهم ويشفي مصابيعهم وفي
النهايه عند سؤال لحضراتكم تفتكروا
الاقتصاد التركي قوي بما فيه الكفايه
علشان يتجاوز الكارثه ويمول عمليه اعاده
الاعمار وينهيها في 12 شهر زي ما اردوغان
قال ولا ده هيكون صعب والاقتصاد التركي
هيتاثر لفتره اطول من كده هتابع كل
اجاباتكم في التعليقات بفكركم للي عايز
اشتري اسهم او ذهب ما تنسوش تشوفوا شركه
اكسنس هتلاقوا رابط تحت الفيديو ما تنسوش
تشتركوا في القناه زي ما اتفقنا ويا ريت
لو عجبتكم الحلقه تعملوا لايك وشير
للفيديو واهم حاجه تحكوا لاصحابكم
وحبايبكم عننا يمكن يستفيدوا سلام
[موسيقى]